when I write a character that doesn't
say a lot doesn't get it across a lot in
in dialogue and doesn't have that many
story beats I tend to write those
characters more prose like I tend to
write them a little bit more like a
novel and I'm putting a lot of stuff in
there that you guys the audience is
never gonna see and you're never
supposed to see it but it's there for
the reader but it's also it's meant for
the actor and so it gives the actor like
a sense of who this guy is I wrote a
whole prose chapter of exactly what
happened on the boat all right it was
called misadventure
and there you find out exactly what
happened I'm not telling you guys all
right but Brad knows in the case of
describing Rick Dalton's career is
filmography his situation that he had to
the situation he has now I wrote that as
not just like a chapter and a book I
wrote it like a chapter of a film book
like a film book about Rick Dalton it
was called the man who would be McQueen
and frankly to tell you the truth it was
when Leo read that is what finally
pushed him over the edge to say yes